days you can't take two steps on
potsdamer platz without running in to
one of these the official bag of the
66th berlin film festival every year the
festival puts out a special edition bag
to celebrate the film's this year's bag
is gray made of wool has a leather
handle and a zipper I think it's pretty
cool but who cares what I think let's
see what the fans think Papa's got a
friend sorry crazy i said we had to
choose the colors i chose pink is very
creative good designer and the good
festival I think it's awesome were you
here last year I was how does this bag
compared to last year's bag uh this bag
looks significantly fancier than last
year's bag sorry can you just tell me
what do you think about this year's
Berlin alibag oh it's much better than
the last year i like it i really like it
especially the one with the white bear
what was wrong with last year's bag i'm
not sure what to say but maybe like this
one is really fancy i really like it why
did you choose red because i'm not a fan
of think oh burn you know i got the pink
bag can you tell me what you think about
this year's berlin alibag it's amazing
it's specially it's good it's very nice
the jury is still out on which film will
get the golden bear but the fans have
spoken and this bag is a winner I've got
a friend
you